chaque année vous nous conseillez
quelques livres à ajouter sur les listes
du Père Noël mais cette question cette
année pardon il est pas question de
grelots de Rennes ou de vieux monsieur à
barbe blanche non cette année si ça me
fait peur un petit peu quand même votre
sélection aller
monstrueux je vais
bien le monstre Pascal oui alors pour un
Noël monstrueux il faut évidemment et
bien des monstres parce que vous le
savez un les monstres sont les amis des
enfants et les adore évidemment ils font
peur ils sont moches ils sont méchants
mais ils sont surtout drôles quand les
auteurs jeunesse s'en en parlent et puis
ça permet un peu de réinventer les
comptes de Noël alors le premier héros a
déjà été adopté par les enfants c'est le
monstre du placard et pour ce cinquième
tome Antoine Dole et Bruno Salamone et
bien lui propose nous propose une
histoire de Noël ça s'appelle le monstre
du placard déteste Noël c'est publié
chez Acte Sud junior et cette fois le
monstre est bien vit l'effervescence de
Noël il écrit sa liste de cadeaux vous
savez il fabrique des gâteaux mais il
fait plein de bêtises comme d'habitude
alors que le Père Noël est bien voit
tout le petit garçon chez qui il vit
évidemment lui n'a jamais rien à se
reprocher mais on dirait que ça lui
plaît ce sabotage des traditions de Noël
alors c'est drôle c'est touchant c'est
plein de mauvais esprits vous le voyez
les dessins sont très très drôles aussi
alors évidemment il faudra pas vous
étonner qui est des petits blagues pour
les adultes comme pour les enfants
puisque l'auteur est bien c'est Antoine
Dole le papa de mortel Adèle qui
cartonne et qui attend un cartonnera
encore sous le sapin cette année je suis
sûr une parfaite alors ce monstre du
placard j'ai bien compris des tests de
Noël mais l'histoire dit-elle s'il aime
vraiment recevoir des cadeaux ça c'est
la question quand même mais Pascal tout
le monde aime les cadeaux voyons et les
monstres aussi mais malheureusement on
pense rarement alors en offrir alors les
auteurs maréchal Marty et Xavier Salomon
ont pensé à eux au monstre et ont écrit
ce livre le cadeau des affreux qui est
publié chez Seuil jeunesse alors l'idée
c'est qu'il y a une grande nuit de la
peur qui organisée par le Syndicat des
affreux alors ils sont tous invités la
méchante reine le zombie le loup
évidemment alors commence par un banquet
absolument dégoûtant des toasts à la
limace des yeux croquants pour les chefs
si ça peut vous inspirer et à minuit
quand on ouvre les cadeaux et bien ils
sont personnalisés alors par exemple la
méchante reine reçoit un drone pour
surveiller les princesses qui sont fuis
dans la forêt le loup reçoit une
souffleuse pour que toutes les maisons
s'envolent quand on a besoin d'un traper
les petits cochons je peux pas tout vous
raconter ce livre est vraiment à mourir
de rire vous le voyez en plus c'est un
système de pop-up on ouvre les cadeaux
en même temps que le loup c'est vraiment
un livre qui m'a fait beaucoup rire je
vous le conseille parfait alors pas de
toast à la limace sur nos tables de
réveillon de fêtes de fin d'année
néanmoins comme j'ai un grand chef ici
j'ai envie de vous demander
on pense tous au toast avec le fameux
foie gras avec la grippe aviaire en ce
moment c'est compliqué de trouver du
foie gras en plus c'est de Brive ce sera
pas comme on trouve alors le conseil du
chef ça serait quoi pour mettre sur nos
toast la défaut de limace et bien on
peut déjà aller sur des beurre de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté parce que
aromatiser c'est vraiment exceptionnel
sur des toasts et souvent on a
l'impression que c'est un ingrédient un
petit peu banal mais ça n'est pas du
tout et puis ensuite on peut travailler
les œufs de truite parce qu'on a on a
des belles truites dans Bourgogne
Franche-Comté aussi on peut avoir les
œufs et la truite fumée évidemment
quand vous avez dit beurre on a failli
perdre notre diététicienne je vous ai vu
là
vous êtes rattrapé sur les autres trucs
mais le beurre alors avec modération
bien sûr comme tout c'est un équilibre
Pascal bon parfait allez on va terminer
avec un dernier livre pour tiffanyfer à
qui on a failli faire peur j'ai cru que
quelqu'un les vous retrouver dans la
bibliothèque j'ai rêvé mais j'ai entendu
une porte qui sait tout faire c'est une
intrusion alors peut-être que c'était
l'envie de faire des cadeaux de Noël une
envie très pressante ça doit être ça
d'accord bon on a un jeu pour les
enfants de 11 ans vous avez un roman
fantastique et mystérieux on va terminer
là-dessus qu'est-ce que c'est ça
s'appelle
Oscar Goupil London mystery de Camille
Guenault publié dans la collection
médium chez l'école des loisirs alors
médium c'est à partir de 11 ans c'est à
dire pour les collégiens comme vous êtes
parfaitement bilingue Pascal et vous
avez mis votre veste à paillettes vous
aurez compris que ça se passe à Londres
que le héros
Oscar alors lui s'est retrouvé planté on
peut le dire par ses parents qui sont
partis du jour au lendemain en vacances
et qu'ils lui ont dit va retrouver ta
vieille tente Léonie à Londres et des
brouille-toi avec elle il se trouve
qu'elle déteste les enfants et qu'elle a
mis en stage à la London Gallery alors
un célèbre musée où il va découvrir des
phénomènes étranges des tableaux qui
parlent des disparitions je vous en dis
pas plus c'est drôle c'est passionnant
c'est mystérieux il y a des références à
Harry Potter évidemment puisqu'on est à
Londres ça plaira au collégien et
surtout ça se passe dans le milieu de
l'art donc on découvre et bien les
grands artistes contemporains et puis
des tableaux ça permettra aux enfants
d'aller peut-être chercher à en savoir
plus sur eux et de passer un bon moment
parfait génial moi j'adore je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez
c'est plutôt bien la sélection livre de
la région est d'ailleurs à retrouver
aussi sur le net et les réseaux sociaux
dites-moi vos quêtes maman est-ce que
Eric et Suzanne ont été sages
ça dépend des jours mais le père Noël
passe pour tout le monde je crois super
parfait
2023 merci Tiphaine